est-ce que vous êtes capable de me dire
ce que vous m'avez dit de le dire à la
police ils m'ont dit on a peur des
représailles
alors Malika il y a 3 ans votre fils
était assassiné du dizaine de coup de
couteau en mars dernier c'est son
assassin qui était retrouvé mort au pied
d'un immeuble tout le monde savait pour
votre fils mais la police n'avait jamais
pu arrêter l'assassin faute de
témoignage la peur des représailles
aujourd'hui vous brisez la loi du
silence vous nous raconterez votre
histoire à 20h
[Musique]
Malika Benamar rebonsoir vous êtes né le
16 avril 1965 à Aïn El turque un petit
village au bord de la mer à 16 km d'Oran
en Algérie père Masson mère femme au
foyer elle avait de quoi s'occuper
puisque vous étiez neuf enfants
vous avez deux ans quand votre famille
quitte l'Algérie pour Marseille où vous
installez dans un grand appartement cité
Corot dans les quartiers nord à l'époque
c'était très calme oui oui très très
calme
effectivement vous dites on sent très dé
on se mélange les cathos allez à
l'église les Juifs à la synagogue les
musulmans à la mosquée et le maltain on
allait à l'école tous ensemble
exactement
souvenir négatif alors quand vous êtes
adolescente il y a aucun problème dans
le quartier il y a pas de trafic il y a
pas de règlement de compte à l'époque
pas du tout on ferme même pas les portes
à l'époque je veux dire les porte
d'entrée se fermer rarement revenu de
fêter vos 18 ans lorsque vous perdez
votre maman
et là après quelques mois d'errance sur
la Côte d'Azur pour noyer votre chagrin
vous devenez femme de chambre dans
lequel riz ensuite vous êtes recruté par
une usine de prêt-à-porter et c'est là
que vous rencontrez le père de vos
enfants exactement ouais alors vous avez
deux enfants
Erwan et 5 ans après une petite fille
mais le père de vos enfants
disparaît assez vite du paysage il était
pas fait pour le rôle de père il
assumait pas et apparemment vous lui en
voulez pas beaucoup mais moi je suis là
pour les aimer je suis là pour assumer
après plus d'un an de RMI vous entrez
dans une entreprise de nettoyage vous
travaillez encore aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
toutes ces années après alors
Erwan votre fils il trait dégourdi mais
il est aussi turbulent et même arrogant
en classe il reprend l'épreuve on me
convoqué pour des petits détails vous
comprenez madame c'est gênant pour moi
parce que j'ai d'autres élèves alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe oui il me reprend
pour une virgule il me reprend pour un S
que j'ai oublié voilà alors la fin de sa
troisième
Erwan décroche son brevet haut la main
il gagne sa liberté et là bon il fait
des il fait du scooter avec ses copains
dans le quartier et un jour c'est
l'accident et là vous vous dites
un jour il va renverser quelqu'un il est
pas assuré ça va être très compliqué et
donc vous décidez lui offrir un scooter
alors quand vous constatez que le
scooter bleu est devenu noir vous
comprenez quand même Kerwan comment
s'affiler du mauvais coton je vais
seulement dire je t'averti
je te défendrai pas
attention aux recettes attention vol
mais non mais ne t'inquiète pas ne
t'inquiète pas effectivement vous avez
la certitude qu'il est en train de
changer
Erwan quant à la veille de son entrée en
seconde il veut quitter l'école alors
vous lui dites mais tu vas faire quoi
maintenant il vous répond tu verras tu
verras donc il a passé un concours je le
savais pas passé un BEP de froid et
climatisation en une année il a réussi
et le 29 juin 2007 la police débarque
chez vous
erwan est accusé d'avoir participé au
braquage d'un bureau de tabac et il
fêtera ses 18 ans derrière les barreaux
à la prison de Luynes
alors il va y passer 18 mois mais
finalement enfin c'est un peu des
vacances pour lui il prend pas ça très
mal il le vit pas comme une punition
très grave
on nous met des écrans plats mais même
lui surpris on a des Playstation et en
moi-même je me disais mais j'ai en
prison ou
il m'a dit non il m'a dit ben je
retrouve mes collègues
de quartier
et ben non on se pose des questions en
tant que parents
en janvier 2009 donc sa sortie de prison
Erwan a eu son BEP par correspondance et
là vous l'éloignez du quartier vous
allez vivre dans un appartement des
Restos du Coeur vous êtes trois dans la
même chambre ce qui est effectivement
montre encore une fois votre votre
engagement pour vos enfants et ils
travaillent donc dans la climatisation
elle est panneaux solaires il gagne 1500
euros par mois le 18 juillet 2010 après
son sport et une douche il vous dit
qu'il va manger avec des collègues et il
dit ne m'attends pas maman trois quarts
d'heure plus tard ses collègues
débarquent chez vous et vous disent il
lui est arrivé quelque chose dès qu'on
sait dans quel hôpital il est on vous
appelle
à l'hôpital vous me verrez que son
visage parce que son corps est caché
il a pris 10 coups de couteau dans le
ventre et dans le coeur
oui je suis rentrée et oui j'ai fait mon
fils avec un drap relevé au menton oui
il était déjà froid oui
le mercredi suivant lors du repas de
deuil un jeune répète en boucle une
phrase en arabe
pardonne-moi mon Dieu pardonne-moi mon
Dieu vous dites quand même bizarre ce
garçon mais enfin comme c'est le repas
deuil vous avez autre chose à penser
vous y faites pas spécialement attention
d'ailleurs ce garçon va à la morgue pour
voir votre fils et il assistera même à
l'enterrement et trois semaines après
l'assassinat des Erwan
on vous apprend que ce garçon et
l'assassin
oui on me l'a donné son nom et j'étais
tellement vidé que je ne ressentais plus
rien plus rien ma seule réaction était
de prendre le lendemain le téléphone et
de dire à la police voilà pour les
judiciaires voilà c'est j'ai le nom en
fait c'est l'un des quatre braqueurs du
bureau de tabac qui a tué votre fils en
faisant parler à la police effectivement
les personnes ne veut témoigner dans le
quartier alors qu'elle est des gens qui
avaient assisté à cette histoire c'est
la fameuse
omerta et puis en mars dernier on vous
prévient que l'assassin des Roanne est
mort on a retrouvé son corps criblé de
balle au pied d'une tour des quartiers
Nord
et donc il y aura jamais de procès non
je voulais l'affronter je m'attendais à
un procès je m'attendais à le voir à
m'expliquer je savais qu'il y avait rien
ce qu'il faut se dire mon fils n'est pas
mort d'un trafic de drogue il n'a jamais
touché à la drogue ça a été un braquage
quand il a fait de la prison et cette
assassinat a été une bagarre d'une
futilité banale voilà alors
ça veut dire que tout le monde le savait
mais personne n'a témoigné pour dire
c'est lui donc ça c'est quand même
incroyable c'est c'est ça le mal c'est
le silence des quartiers ils ont peur
des représailles ils ont peur je peux le
comprendre mais ce qui ne savent pas les
gens c'est que
la justice comme oui la justice elle
protège
donc mais vous vous êtes allé voir des
gens qui savaient vous leur avez dit
dites-le par exemple
est-ce qu'ils étaient capables je leur
ai dit est-ce que vous êtes capable de
me dire
ce que vous m'avez dit de le dire à la
police ils m'ont dit en a peur des
représailles parce que ce qu'il faut
savoir le soir même de l'assassinat de
mon fils on est venu armer
je tiens à le dire ses cousins et des
amis est venu menacer les jeunes dans la
cité alors évidemment si les parents de
l'assassin d'Erwan ne l'avait pas
couvert il serait pas mort donc
aujourd'hui vous vous êtes en droit de
dire aux parents de l'assassin de votre
fils c'est vous qui l'avez tué en fait
je me suis toujours posée la question
comment sa mère pouvait le regarder
comment elle pouvait lui faire à manger
comment pouvez
partir en vacances pendant que moi je
pleurais mon fils comment au mois de
décembre elle pouvait partir se louer un
chalet à la neige pendant que moi j'ai
pleuré mon fils pendant que moi j'ai
essayé de ramasser le plus d'éléments
possible pour avoir une justice une
arrestation
voilà vous n'avez pas de haine Malika
mais une grande colère effectivement
contre les familles qui ferment les yeux
et aujourd'hui vous faites partie d'un
collectif qui s'appelle le collectif du
premier juin c'est une association de
maire qui veulent briser l'omerta des
cités oui je suis rentrée dans ce
collectif parce qu'il fallait que je
fasse quelque chose
et on attend prochainement un
rendez-vous avec Madame Taubira
monsieur Vals aussi voilà parce qu'on
arrange Marseille on arrange Marseille
on arrange on fait des fêtes énormes la
culture 2013 mais les quartiers nord on
les oublie on finance le centre-ville
et puis les quartiers nord ils existent
plus voilà ils existent dans les
règlements de comptes merci de votre
témoignage merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu